Do you always go for six-month agreement or go for 12 and reduce to six?
You can go whatever the hell you want. Like it depends like
Like honestly for me and this is the same thing
I like the reason I like six months ray is because I personally I
Like I don't want to be stuck with someone that sucks
Like just as bad as they don't want to be stuck in a contract. I don't want to be stuck in a contract
I had this exact same thing happen with a piece of uh, with a property that I own a
Uh an office i'm subleasing all the little offices out and we had this client come in
And or this potential tenant and they were like, yeah, we'll probably just do a 12 month and honestly i'm like
I don't know how much money these guys have they say they're gonna park their vehicles outside
They kind of seem like they're like, I don't know. I was just getting this vibe and i'm like I told my wife
I'm like, let's just do a six month so that we are not stuck with these bastards for for a year
And
They've been really good so far
But we did a six month and honestly like their vehicle like they parked their vehicles in the house or at the office
They're not super nice vehicles. They paid in cash. I'm like do these guys even have money and honestly
A couple days after we signed the six month. I told I turned to my wife. I'm like, aren't you glad we did six months?
So ray the reason I do a six month instead of a 12 typically is because I I honestly
Who knows maybe I get a better offer maybe I find somebody else that's willing to pay more money
So I would specifically tell you if you're if you're at a price point
You don't think is what you want to be at do a shorter agreement
Ask kareem because I think it was him
He told me the same exact thing as he he was going for like a six month ended up doing a two month
And he's like dude, i'm actually kind of glad I did a two month now because i've been absolutely crushing it
So now at the end of you know in the next four weeks, he's gonna be able to bump that up
So that's just my personal thing
There's a pro though to having a 12 month because then you have to worry about it
So, um, I know burhan, uh signed a 12 month the other day on a towing deal
So it's up to you